-We love our audience.
We really do love you guys.
You watch us every night,
but right now, we want to change
things up and watch you.
We asked you guys at home
to send us some fun
or unique talents that you have.
We got submissions
from thousands of people
all over the world, and we're
gonna meet some of them now.
It is time for
"Show Me Something Good."
-♪ Show me something good ♪
♪ Show me something good ♪
♪ Show me something good,
just show me ♪
-All right.
Let's met our first guest.
Hello. What's your name,
and where are you from?
-Hi, I'm Kalan Hauser.
-Kalan.
-From Los Angeles, California.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Kalan from L.A.!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All the way from L.A.
Thank you for coming over
to the east coast.
I appreciate this.
What is your talent, and how did
you realize you could do this?
-So, my talent is, I'm gonna be
walking on my hands...
-That's big.
-...but at the same time,
I'm gonna be reciting
digits of pi.
Um, so, the numerical --
you know, numbers --
-Oh, my gosh, yeah, I know.
-Yes.
-3.14 -- that's about where I...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and then it goes
far after that.
-Wow! All right.
So this is an amazing --
And you realized --
you were just doing --
you were walking on your hands,
and you go,
"I should do something else
with this"?
-Yeah, I was gymnast growing up,
and there was contest in, like,
middle school to see who can,
like, remember the most numbers.
And I still remember to this
day, so, I was like,
"Why not do it together?"
-This is so exciting.
Kalan -- Roots, do you have any,
like, walk on your hands music?
I have no --
[ Laughter ]
What do you think?
Whenever you're ready, bud.
I don't want to freak you out.
-I'm good.
-Do I stand here?
-Yes, right there is fine.
Am I good to go?
-Go for it.
-3.1415926535...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...897932384626...
...4338327950288419716939937...
...51058209749445923078164062...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...8620899862...
-Be careful!
-...8034...
-Kalan, be careful.
Come down, come down.
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yo!
Thank you.
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you so much!
That was amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
All right,
let's meet our next guest.
Hello. What's your name,
and where are you from?
-Kohlmann Dean.
I'm from Salt Lake City, Utah.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kohlmann, Salt Lake City.
I love Salt Lake City.
What -- What is your talent,
and then how did you realize
that you could do this talent?
-Well, I'm going to be rapping
to a beat with only bird sounds.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
And how --
how is everything at home?
Everything okay?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I didn't have
many friends growing up.
-Yeah, I understand.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so you -- and you --
maybe you just --
I'm assuming you just
kind of had a whistle once,
and you go, "Oh,
kind of sounds like bird"?
-Yeah.
Yeah, it started out like that.
-And then you --
you're a fan of hip-hop music?
And you're like, "Oh, I wonder
if I could put a beat to this"?
Wow.
-Pretty much.
[ Laughter ]
-I read the biography, yeah.
All right.
How -- How can I help you?
What can I do?
Can I give you a beat?
What do we --
-Uh, a track would be great.
Yeah, a beat.
-All right,
do we have a beat for...?
All right, for Kohlmann,
and whenever you...
[ Funk music plays ]
[ Whistling to the beat ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Whistling continues ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's awesome, man!
That sounded great!
-Thank you.
-That sounded great.
-Thank you very much
for being here.
Appreciate it.
[ Chuckles ]
Let's meet our final guest here.
Hello. What is your name?
Hi!
-Hello!
-Beautiful.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Laura, St. Louis, Missouri.
-Ah, St. Louis.
We love you, Laura.
Welcome.
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Laura, you have
very beautiful hair.
-Thank you.
-What is your talent tonight?
-I spin things by my braids.
-Mm.
And when did -- how did you
realize that you could --
you could do this?
-Um...
You try things out,
and you see if they work.
I have no idea.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like, what -- do you just --
-I don't remember.
-No, you're not gonna do this.
-But these --
it's the spooky season.
So...
-Yes, it is spooky season,
but these are heavy.
-I'm gonna --
I'm gonna spin pumpkins.
-Wait, but this is
a heavy pumpkin.
You're gonna --
-Yeah, do you want -- do you
want to feel the weight?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I mean --
-Thanks.
-That's a legit pumpkin.
-That's a really legit pumpkin.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you sure
you're okay doing this?
-Yeah.
I've done this lots of times.
-But what was --
[ Laughter ]
What, did it start with
Christmas ornaments,
or what did it --
-Yeah, it did.
-Right. And then it grew to --
-Grandma's Christmas.
-Yeah, grandma's
Christmas ornaments.
But then it led to like...
-And then --
-...20-pound pumpkins?
-Spooky season's
the best season.
-Spooky season is
the best season, yes.
All right, what can I do here?
-Um, some jams.
-Okay, Roots, do we have
any jams for spinning?
♪♪
Okay.
-Okay.
You're gonna have to step back.
Okay.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo!
Y-o-o-o-o!
That's what I'm talking about
right there!
Let's get all of our
amazing guests back out here!
That's all the time.
Whoa!
That was fantastic!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
That was awesome!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Give it up.
My thanks to Kalan,
Kohlmann, Laura.
If you have a fun talent,
I want to see it.
Go to the-tonight-show.com/
showmesomethinggood
to submit a video.
We'll be right back with
Rachel Maddow, everybody.
♪♪